all right it's time for this week's
hatred mail it's an interesting one this
week but first a reminder what is hatred
mail
we're so all right it's wrong patriot
mail written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom
okay so hatred mail is often
conspiratorial but there's something
charming about this one because it is so
nuanced it's like those Russian
matryoshka dolls the the successively
smaller and smaller dolls take a listen
to this week's hatred mail
I knew pac-man was an undercover Bernie
shill pretending to shill for Warren
tell me David Pakman isn't a shill vie
for the evil and powerful this is
exactly the kind of thing a shill would
do though pretend to be for Bernie get
our hopes up that bernie is winning then
when the moment comes you tell us that
Warren or Biden Hackman's favorite by
the way caught back up Tulsi has 61
percent approval in her district and her
challenger as a corporate shill yeah I'd
like to bet my money in Tulsi once again
Pakman shows his true colors as another
corporate sellout I kind of loved the
nuance I'm actually a Bernie shill
but what I've done in order to hide that
is to pretend to be a shill for Warren
so that no one notices that while I
appear to be shilling for Elizabeth
Warren I'm actually secretly fueling for
Bernie Sanders because that's actually
my priority how about I call it like I
see it
there's no hidden agenda at all
sometimes I will agree with what one
candidate says does it proposes or
believes sometimes I might disagree with
that exact same candidate and there is
no shadow agenda or strategy where I am
trying to create an environment in which
my true preference will be hidden but
still be able to influence my audience
in that direction I've told everybody
I'm a Bernie Warren
I think by the time Massachusetts votes
the primary will by-and-large be decided
I will eventually tell you who I vote
for and I won't participate in the types
of attacks on the progressive candidates
beyond critiquing policy I disagree with
which of course I do that has the
potential to hurt the Democratic chances
in November of 2020 that's my position
I'm not hiding the agenda from you that
is my agenda I have one but it is not to
secretly shill for one candidate by
pretending to shill for another fight
hate reott ISM by using the coupon code
hate free at forty if you get a
membership at join pakman.com and use
the coupon code h8 e RI ot for 0 you'll
save 40% and it's like a middle finger
to the hatreds